it's been seven years since the release
of the original leviathan and five years
for the original katana and boy have
creative and razer brought them back in
their v2 states but of course the
question remains amidst the host of
under monitor audio systems out there
which of the two v2s are too good to be
true
firstly i need to set this straight
razer is that it's called a gaming
peripherals company and i personally
cannot put them in the same lane as
creative because they're an audio
company so they're definitely on
different planes just need to get this
out of the way also that when it comes
to audio i'm just really spoiled like
really spoiled like honestly spoiled and
not an audiophile kind of way when i was
born with hd800 on my hit but i have an
understanding of it also i'm a gamer i'm
a gamer hello the leviathan v2 isn't bad
but it isn't amazing compared to the
katana v2 and psy comparing prices the
leviathan v2 cost 250 us dollars and the
katana v2 costs 230 us dollars set up
for both sound bars are just plug and
play so they even out in that sense but
before we continue on here's a message
from our friends at logitech here at
geek culture we love our keyboards
especially with the all new logitech mx
keys mini an elegant and functional
keyboard its ultra responsive rounded
keycaps are super stable and quiet for
more productivity there are buttons to
enable dictation microphone audio
control and emojis the backlit keys
illuminate when you get close and
matches the lighting of the environment
you're in it lasts up to 10 days on a
full charge or five months with the
backlights turned off to find out more
about the logitech mx keys mini and
their latest range of products head over
to logitech.com
okay so connectivity options the
leviathan v2 loses out on connectivity
options with only usb support via usb8
usbc cable which means there isn't much
to fall back on if your pcs driver
issues in comparison to the original
leviathan which has aux and optical in
options so i don't understand why razer
would downgrade and upgrade sure there's
bluetooth but we all know bluetooth and
pcs don't exactly have the best
relationship it does work well with your
phone for low latency music playback
though and i haven't any issues with
that yet we'll have to see how it
performs in the long run however the
katana v2 on the other hand has all
those options in addition to hdmi arc
and 65 out ports if you're into that
also a headphone port at the front of
the soundbar for easier access compared
to the v1 which is at the back something
both leviathans have none of so why
would razer limit the options i don't
know simplifying tech is great but this
is a little too much it takes away a lot
of the options the consumer has with the
katana v2 and we like options so the
katana v2 wins in this regard also the
leviathan v2 doesn't come with a remote
like the katana v1 and v2 and a lot of
original leviathan owners have been
asking for that for quite a while now
getting into aesthetics both katanas and
the violence are good looking sound bars
i mean you gotta be honest i like the
smaller form factor on the vitam v2 and
how stylish it is with its great black
textures compared to the v1 and they
come with angled feet which is a nice
touch if you need the extra elevation
the leviton v2 in comparison fits snugly
under your monitor and i honestly have
no complaints about extra realistic then
we have chroma rgb it doesn't look as
impressive compared to rgb served up by
the katana v2 which diffuses beautifully
though it needs to be set you can
customize 18 sections of the lighting
individually for the leviathan v2 and
both katanas can't do that now you got
to use the navs to change the lighting
on the leviathan but if you want to
change the lighting with your phone you
got to disconnect the leviton completely
from the pc
and to your phone via bluetooth and just
why the creative app on my phone lets
you change things up while you're
connected to your pc so we found
greatest way of connection very much
bizarre we'll get into the apps a bit
more later on okay so sound quality with
the leviton v2 you're getting two 95
millimeter full range drivers two 20
millimeter tweeters two passive radiator
drivers and a 144 millimeter subwoofer
the katana v2 meanwhile has two 63
millimeter mid-range drivers two 19
millimeter tweeters and a 165 millimeter
subwoofer and also a mic which is still
impressive that they managed to fit it
on there so to start the leviathan v2 is
honestly
pretty good it's well balanced highs are
crisp but surprisingly the base isn't as
punchy as i thought it would be given
how razer likes to tune their audio
stuff but that's also probably a new
part because you know it's well balanced
so i guess they were going for that
sound staging is wide and imaging is
somewhat detailed listening to bands
like total toe arch tremors and
periphery guitars and vocals sound crisp
and somewhat full but you're gonna need
to play around with the eq on synapse to
get the drums and bass sounding punchier
gaming wise i was playing apex legends
and i'm able to pick out where the
enemies are coming from footsteps are
detailed and so are gunshots
which makes the leviathan v2 a pretty
fun samba to have while playing games
all in all the leviathan v2 does the job
well whether you're playing music or
gaming and of course it gets loud i
don't find myself going beyond 30 of my
volume so at its most basic usage as an
under monitor audio system it succeeds
in delivering especially with thx
spatial audio it adds a little more
depth to your music and gameplay in a
way i do like what razer has done here
they've made a significant improvement
they've made a significant improvement
over the original but of course that's
relative to them now not even comparing
the leviathan v2 to the katana v2 but
the katana v1 sound is a lot more full
and warm sound staging is much wider and
imaging is more precise the leviton v2
sounds very boxed up and flat compared
to the katana v1 i'd say the leviathan
and katana v2s are on par when it comes
to how loud they can go but the katana
v2 is definitely more detailed in terms
of articulation instruments are more
pronounced than full gunshots and
explosions are punchier while footsteps
and imaging are more accurate also
turning scout mode on with the katana v2
which is an eq of sorts amps up your
entire gaming experience i'm pretty sure
audiophiles out there will get a kick
out of listening to this now
software
snaps as well synapse it's oftentimes
jankier than more software out there but
when it works it works the interface is
very simple you can switch between
stereo and thx there's a volume bar you
can choose to turn on center focus you
can even assign another audio device and
hold down the source button on the
leviathan which is actually really handy
when you want to swap out over to
headphones without having to navigate
the windows interface lastly there's the
equalizer which i've experienced some
issues with sometimes i cannot get them
to switch between the five options but
more often than not i can't for some
reason they'll probably patch it up at
some point but as of now it's not at its
best i tried the game eq option and i
was just stressed out hell the music eq
option is still the best out of the lot
or you know just customize your own the
creative app has a lot more to offer
with eq options for different games and
scenarios voice modifiers a decoder
scout mode and the sexify option which
you need to download separately
all in all it's very comprehensive back
to controlling the leviathan your phone
numb
you gotta download two separate apps
yeah to control both audio and rgb
but the creative app is all in one and
you can tweak the same exact options on
the pc app razer is probably working on
creating an all-in-one app but there's
no release date yet and that's another
point for the creative katana v2
conclusion
in terms of customization connectivity
options and performance i would avoid
the points to the katana series and i
think many of y'all out there would
choose it over leviathans despite its
bigger price tag again it should be
noted that creative is an audio company
so this is their playing field that
raises on if razer added that aux port i
honestly would not mind getting it
because it actually is a decent sambar
but of course it restricts you to your
pc if you don't mind the lack of
connectivity options the leviathan works
well enough for the casual gamer and
listener of course not all of you out
there would agree with me since this is
all based on my personal experience with
both products so if you have any
questions leave them in the comment
section down below and i'll do my best
to answer them
follow us on all our socials and if you
like this video leave a like and
subscribe to us we've got tons of videos
coming your way this is ineo and i'm
gonna go blast the shot of them
[Music]